[Music]
for years our world has been at peace
but something is coming I can feel it
dark forces are upon us
find these beasts or whatever they are
our world is dying there is nothing to
go back to if our people are to survive
we must make a whole media whatever
happens
what happens if we do not unite our
world will perish this doesn't need to
happen there is one who may help us
there is no no but with the humans help
there could be
why are you here to save our people can
we trust him
the beasts they should all be destroyed
are you sure that
[Music]
we'll protect the king you and I inside
with a human against your own kind
there's the suicide we have no choice we
should attack with full force whatever
you plan to do do it now
you
hey youtubers is Charlie happy Blizzcon
we finally got the official warcraft
trailer so let's break it down
real quick reminder - I'm doing a
giveaway for one of the purchasable epic
mounts all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so if you guys are watching the
feed this morning they later do some of
the cast on stage most of the people
most of the big characters we see in
this trailer if I can introduce Toby
Kebbell Durotan Ben Foster
Maddy's dominant Koopa the king Lane
[Applause]
Clancy Brown Black Hand Daniel Wu golden
[Music]
and pull a patent Girona
just to place the movie in the time
lighting it kind of picks up where the
first game picks up orcs V humans as you
can see the narrative of the game agram
is like the protagonist of the orcs he's
gonna try and form an alliance with the
humans Lothar here is kind of like his
counterpart but obviously on the orcs
side you have people like Clancy Brown
playing black hand who aren't gonna be
really happy about that
you have King Lane Rin domine Cooper
here who isn't sure what to do and then
swirling in the background we have
cooled down and Medivh so so obviously
they're gonna have their own agenda -
despite the fact that they're both
serving the orcs and the humans
yay for squishy cloth wares it is really
fun seeing little baby thrall there just
look how elite he is this is also one of
our first looks at der Oh tan - he's
gonna be the leader of one of the other
work factions but if it's not clear
during the orc narrative despite the
fact that they have all these big
characters autumn is the main character
really I think if this is like a grim
and Lothar's movie and then you just
have a bunch of other big characters in
it it looks like we're getting a taste
of the Burning Legion so I'm guessing
that's where a cool dad comes in and
that provides some of the impetus for
our imp to try and form an alliance with
the humans now remember this is just the
first of many movies so if you're up on
your Warcraft lore you know gold Dan
stretches across a lot of orc leaders
and a lot of them appear in this movie
so I'm expecting gold AMA deep some of
the bigger background characters to
carry forward in any future movies that
they do it's just in the official
Warcraft lore ghoul Dom manipulates a
lot of the orcs like algorithm ends up
battling with a lot of the other
chieftains eventually golden installs
black can't hear
Clancy Brown's character as the puppet
leader of the United Horde we also to
talk about Coronas character because it
seems like she's gonna be a link between
orcs and humans although secretly she's
part drainie I don't know how they're
going to figure into this movie it seems
like this movies mostly focusing on the
conflict between orcs and humans so I'm
not expecting a whole lot of training
stuff maybe Easter eggs for future
movies so I think for the short term
we're just supposed to think of her as a
link between orcs and humans but you
know then you know secretly at the end
of the movie they might find out that
she's part drainie and then push that
into the second movie we'll see I think
it just depends on how successful this
first movie is I think they want to keep
it as simple as possible and Warcraft
lore gets really complicated Game of
Thrones does the same thing when it
adapts stuff for the TV show like it
just it makes it a little bit more
linear a little bit easier to follow but
the good thing is is that this
successful enough they'll spin it down
into a big Marvel Universe and you'll
get all kinds of warcraft movies
probably Starcraft movies too eventually
but what I'm really hoping that we see
one of the big surprises I'm hoping to
see is Gould on invoking Sargeras
something big from the Burning Legion
either kil Jaeden arch Amon Sargeras
there has to be some villain that's
bigger than the orcs in the humans like
they'll be fighting each other but they
have to unite because some bigger threat
from the Burning Legion comes along we
are way too early for the Lich King not
expecting a whole lot of dragons either
but in terms of progression just expect
the movies to follow the timeline of the
games with the idea that if they cut
things out they might bring them back
later like if they don't reference the
drainie in the first movie they might
bring them on later or if we don't need
Sargeras in the first movie you know we
might meet him in the second or the
third there'll be a whole bunch of
movies and Blizzard Activision just
launched a TV and film studios so
they're actually gonna be producing a
lot more content I mean it's starting
with call of duty and Skylanders but
eventually you'll see Warcraft and
Starcraft TV shows I think like a lot of
other big film things they want to do
it'll just depend on how successful this
first movie is I think it's gonna be
awesome but I all say like the biggest
thing that I'm looking forward to is
seeing the Burning Legion just wreck
everybody now if you didn't see it I
just posted a Star Wars trailer video so
after you get through all that footage
after you get through all the awesome
footage while you're watching The Bluest
compete be sure to update all of your
Blizzard games I actually just had to
log in for the first time in a week or
two to update hearthstone Warcraft and
Starcraft 2 I totally admit to just auto
buying anything that Blizzard sells so
even though I haven't played Starcraft 2
in a while I'm totally auto buying
legacy of the void I feel like you have
to one of the big knocks against destiny
is the fact that it has almost no
narrative is almost no Lord there's
almost no story Blizzard is one of the
best companies when it comes to stuff
like that they have special people on
their team whose job is only to develop
the lore so everybody grab your rain
gear watch the trailer a couple more
times here actually you can click here
I'll just add a link so you can loop the
trailer forever and ever and you can
click here for the new Star Wars trailer
I just posted thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys this weekend
you